негайно
світлові лідер за пензлем фіктивних
сукачів про тулку
одну застанем збитим він ви на вибори дав
адже вона США
кільки втечі у fair and asti nos gusta
і
на місяць подаєте кілька десятків на 1000
за явно вранці вони політичному прогулянку
обидва статуси біженця
зараз тихіше приїжджають з єретику сувар і
серби avanti їхньому акті шатла шлюбу та
і людей часто дістанете розмішує і вісь
у таких рідких контейнерах згинуло
гулі то відразу явно keep блазні зріс
лайки кисть українців деркачова 2013 його
this україни в павуках protool куди фарин
приїхала бути по 140 громадян
то в 2014 уроки їх не тільки дорослим.
яшау 20 ру
ще місяця по точному руку подаєте по
300 але найвища у вигляді українців має
тебе спарюються патча ти в ньому дуже і
нового жити а в темно від них що штука я
вигадку чекають на блоці його проживання
на ритку нові знаєш і місця
безперспективність розтягуються на
рукою дано чан їм ярослав розум із сім'ї
це рик равлик вріс по лобі і виході на
донбасі проїхавши дурні дні ви не менше
але cool та стіл відразу мила що Power
that i собі шині куди падав і заяву на
ранок і манячи при тулку відсіку ось і
рішення сім'ю ярослава вид провали за
сотні кілометрів види з них роду ніж у
не менше не на ямщики над краї в
tabbert для біженців там звичайно був
жах спали на матрацах на підлогу там тут
на баржах би спала на матрацах просто на
лось на баттоні
щоб апельсина pudge а вся ж лектор
бування поза машиною в я кості шок від шоу
про тулку необхідно пройти реєстрацію
тому що вони пудра гармату чиновники
кабінет і на зареєструєшся великий на
1 пишно it's all up a trap від ф-цій
кабінет було просто нам url його
тільки у я бачу by так і корда разів
шишкою ок всяким на до зубів буки в
тусуються люди в тісні вина within йому
жив його рука піднята
а ти хто вище зі зростанням починають кістку
the cliff теми що у хадисі через голову
листи
ми досягаємо випадок роботи в тій
кабінет базі щеня чарівної людини по
мужикам якщо а табору родену ярослава
особливими в тему про тулку запитаємо до
соціальних служб та волонтери ви їм
вдалося аналу води 3 скромний привід що
місяця кожен член сім'ї відриваючи на
відпочинок їх від шувані бути по 300 євро
зіграв у не менше не льодова ви 100
чаю ми не сварка багато чому від цих гаїв то
сидить і тут без роботи я давно вже ходжу
тут я говорю що хочу проти ти краще
знає і роботу то винні собі тих
соціальних виплат віджатися що я з
хороший на рубеус путін в симптом
чеку та на рішення про надання про тулку
проти ти за буруни але так само як
і вільно вітрила тис вони мишачу
Ярослав спочиваєте ізольованим вигляд
кольору
така ситуація може за тих 1000 надовго
ж burn безумець уявити про вузи і
сную організації про азіль як позики і
тип це ним і біженців у не менше не
треба насадку двічі на початку яких
іскри забавний не мати до влади прибираючи
стратегію в чику ваня вугіллям і підсікаємо
бо пуда його масок ситуація розвивається
дали б на початку конфлікту члени
ведена kosis турині з розслідування
міша причина того чому розріз прав
біженців затягується кулі заявки кістки
біженці століття суті зросла небо і поза
категорії біженців праворуч та яких
розгадають фітнес ну шведку ланцюга роду
сімки через західних балкан він і
шведку прямий вигляд полетить творець шоу
видного
жарт прямий трохи по вигляді сріту мвд
більше статус біженця надають шляхи
меншим дало та тема живий 2 чиї душі чика
ти ціл чикого не дуже важко поза сферою
проти вуст них місяців правозахисникам
постимо він відходить свинки там mail і вигляд
українці поза машиною багата хто сп
одягається доб умах ти пологи ніж річки
зазнала вигляду бойових дій на сході
україни за краще тис не менше не в
team статисти до свічки шанси нація в
українців mather не на захід до
німецького федерального відомства
випробувань міграції чи біженців дойче
велле отримала так уве творити
на сьогодні біженцям з донецькою та
луганської областей protool окуні машині
не треба yet a boy's але я
альтернативно можна вся пара їзду до
мирних регіоні в Україні я русло смак
виду мені ще шанс і при марні
як усі битви буду негативну сама
ж стати на вищому моральному червоному
фінансовим ударом по німецьких родичах
ярослава
вона вимкнена все на них може час
класу частини ну ви трат пов'язаних з
продування і повідай нам про хочу в про
толку від же всіх то робот запрошення
руди ніж обидва друзям пана собою і
фінансові зубів в'язання утен ярославців
година по дівається, що йому дадуть шанс патча
ти але вижити та обійме шині а g-power то
тис і йому нікуди